thank you
chilling bro
get me I'm getting you [__]
you look amazing
that's amazing
huh
I heard I heard hey Bart let's go and I
was like
I grabbed all my [__] and I went around
the corner here and then I'm listening
to you guys and then I hear I can hear
everything and I can hear Barton go like
hey Steve are you there
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we're talking
about defend look the economy's kind of
weird and stuff like that it's time to
defend buying expensive [__] go let's go
buy an expenses
where do you need all these cars and
[__] for dude yeah I only got one car
you got [__] multiple Vehicles no I
only got one a truck
what are you what are you at now I got
three trucks
he has three reliable ones I have three
trucks but they're in different states
that's a pretty good Flex honestly
three license plates too I have three
license plate no two no I have two do
you have the rainbow um Hawaii um
license plate yep that's cool Super
Rainbow I'm Pride every day right and
don't you don't you have two of the same
truck yes I do I have a 2023 Tacoma one
in Hawaii one in Nevada that's tight
same color no oh yeah
unbolt your plates and just swap the
plates that'll be hilarious like I just
go and take my Nevada plates well I mean
people do ship their cars to Hawaii so
it's not that rare because you'll see
like Virginia plates and stuff and
you're like wow especially military
people you drove over the ocean yeah I
have an argument actually to buying uh
luxury things yeah during like I think
we're dressed for this sometimes are
tough right
you're still creating jobs
you know yeah going to Louis Vuitton
like you're giving the Louis Vuitton CEO
a job yeah yes I see
you're still stimulating the economy
because the thing is if nobody spent
money from Rich all the way down to work
in class and poor that that means
everything gets [__] but if even in
recessions like Ballers keep spending
right more incredible and that's what
keeps things going even though
the rest of us poor folks don't have
anything to really spend on Colleen do
you like designer stuff uh I don't I
don't like anything with name brands
anything not even one thing right
anything like it I like I like
what about L cameras well that's
different
it's different because I feel like
there's like Gucci and everything right
like some people might not like Gucci
wallets but they might have a Gucci like
fishing pole they went straight to like
clothing and like accessories
um that I don't like name brands for but
obviously when it comes to like quality
products in cinema of course like you
don't got a [__] Minolta camera yeah
what's that I don't know
right yeah [__] yeah you probably got
the cool [__] like a Lumix the Sony or
something a Fuji film you know Fujifilm
yeah like Ryan you probably use Yamaha
and [__] sure yeah yeah yeah
I will I will defend brands in the in
the case that you don't have to buy it
as many times if you get a good one
that's true it does luxury always have
quality nope it's wonderful branding
luxury or a luxury guarantees quality of
life when flexing on others yeah yeah
quality of life is wonderful we're
dripping in luxury right now we are yeah
I feel like on my skin you know some
Brands some I would say some brands are
though like for guns I try to buy the
most expensive one in it like the
reliability and how it works is like 10
times better than the regular like gun
so yeah I agree you know kills people 10
times faster yeah well he doesn't check
it out more dams their souls if you run
like a thousand rounds through it you're
gonna [__] kill a thousand people
which is yes yeah but then if you have a
gun that's jamming all the time you're
like [__]
maybe yourself too yeah and sometimes
like if you know what you're getting the
resale value is so good like a Rolex or
like a wonderful Toyota because like
when when I had this uh cool little
Rolex I was just like man [__] War
it's brand new it's so nice had it for
like five years and I was like oh I
probably didn't wear it for the last two
years so I went to sell it and I got 500
extra for it and I bought it brand new
that's crazy so that it happens like
that sometimes you know I mean you can't
you probably can't do it on a Louis
Vuitton wallet but like the Rollies you
can like that wasn't meant to be luxury
it was actually like Rolex and like
Omega they're meant to be like really
really precise instruments like a Range
Rover that like it's not meant to be
yeah the actual divers and [__]
astronauts used it and then rich people
like to buy crazy [__] so they're like
dude is that what the the watch that
went to the deepest parts of the the
ocean and then they kind of like the
market drove it up yeah the market
elevated it when those two brands are
actually supposed to just be like
instruments so G-Shock has a chance
they're coming back baby do you remember
when um Ben Baller was Diamond studying
the G-Shocks that was a very popular
thing to do that's how they elevated the
G-Shock I would love to ice this thing
out dude it's already pretty icy
honestly yeah that's pretty freezing
that's pretty heavy he's shocked dude I
didn't carry that on your wrist you
should ice out your crypto Ledger
I should do that actually but I need to
have a reason to do it so right now
everything's on that's on his trash
worthless trash if you guys were a
luxury clothing brand which one
resonates mostly with you I love well
until they [__] up recently I loved um
valenciaga Balenciaga bro that was my
[__] you're a Balenciaga kind of big
time I could see the shoes on you but
then they're like hey we have a new
clothing line about [__] kids and I
was like Jesus dude this is crying crazy
for me
I never see anyone at the Balenciaga
store but the Chinese really Chinese
love it they never seen the marketing
that or like they never seen the the the
the cancel [__] that we did and even if
they did they're like we don't care
because the kid already make the
Balenciaga do they really don't when I
was in China I remember that even the
like the camera guy or the grip or any
any even the lowest like level of uh
people working on set had like off-white
they had like dope ass Brown yeah and
they would tell me is because of the
status like they'll just save up their
money and go and buy that [__] so they
could like belong yeah just so they can
like like uh that way they'll be noticed
in the same like way but this is a
discount way because people think it's
Versace yeah
and then they have to really look and go
oh it's not dude I went me and Nikki
were on the strip and uh I was with her
parents so we're taking her to like the
touristy areas and they wanted to go to
the [__] Venetian and ride the
gondolas until we found it's like 700
for four people
actually I'm exaggerating but it was
nuts we're like we're not doing this
[__] for a 10 minute ride we go back and
forth [__] though [__] that but we while
we were on the way Nikki and her mom
wanted to go check out this like cool
art store so we go in there and I'm
dressed in one of these because I was on
this trip and I have to do it it's my
[__] brand right I have to represent
my brand and [__] right so so I'm in the
store and this guy completely ignores
everybody else in the store and just
comes up to me and bugs me the entire
time and we're in the tiger suit this is
Amazon 47 dude dude you're a big bomber
and this guy's like this guy's like oh
you like tiger and I'm like yeah I like
I like yeah I do and he's like oh he's
like
he's taking out these um Swarovski
Tigers like little sculptures and [__]
and he's like oh 10 grand very
reasonable I'm like oh really Tim good
and I'm like hey Nikki what do you think
I'm like my wife's in charge of
everything you know how it is
and then he's like yes no very good and
he's like and he's and then he um he's
like oh maybe you like he said maybe you
like white tiger I'm like yeah yeah I
love white tigers
more rare and I'm telling you there's
people walking in the store probably
like Jewish bankers and [__] [__]
Kings of the world probably and this
guy's bugging me Princess walking in
he's shooting all them like they're
[__] commoners like like oh no go get
ice cream down there go get ice cream
who gives a [__] about you get the [__]
out of here so that [__] works though
yeah yeah is it that store that has the
craziest sculptures and all that yeah
and it's got like chairs that look that
make you feel like you're a prince yup I
know that story there's a video of
Michael Jackson going in and shopping
there and he was just like takes that
place I'll take that I'll take that well
he's like two of those it's like half a
million that's that place oh [__] dude
that place is [__] hilarious yeah
yeah that guy was so short and I was
like I was like man I was like you know
what if this doesn't go with what my
wife wants to do she's gonna bust my
[__] balls and I was like we gotta go
cause we're going to one of the shows
but I'll probably be back give me the
card and he gave me the card you know
what I love about that spot it's like 19
it's the epitome of 1980s new money
exactly so when you have money and like
because you're now a new millionaire
like you go there and deck out your
house for Cocaine Cowboys dude
millionaire Mansions people with glass
block walls yep yeah my bar at my place
it was clearly like a cocaine Mansion or
whatever because they have like all that
mirror everywhere and then upstairs they
have mirror everywhere looks tacky as
[__]
that's one of my favorite things to look
at like when I'm looking for homes and
stuff is there's like old school Ballers
that were like that got really rich like
in the 90s or whatever right
and they keep it exactly the same
because they don't buy new [__] yeah and
then they have that they get like
time capsuled so they stay in that and
then you're looking at it and you're
like what the [__] like they never
bothered to modernize it they just keep
buying the same things and they're just
stuck in that era some of that stuff's
cool if they maintain it I saw this one
house where it was like uh it was in
Arcadia and it's like an 80s like baller
home probably some rich Chinese guy
built it with some Lions out front yeah
yeah yeah and then every room has an
intercom wow oh I remember those
like call your [__] kid down there or
whatever that's kind of cool dude
nothing beats chain link fence and two
Mason Lions out front yeah it's like
they say Hey brother I don't think you
know where you live my man like it does
not look like you think it looks
it's for good luck or something dude
that's what it is what's the bushiest
[__] you have Nick you have anything
bougie not really yeah you do you
[__] lives sack of [__] I bet
you I'll name it right now but oh yeah
sure what is it Jiu Jitsu geese nah bro
nah you gotta Show Your Role you already
have Show Your Role yeah but they're
like 200 but that's the Gucci of that
[__] though that's a lot of money
because they're old it costs like 40
bucks
bro you're crazy like people people
they're like 100 121. every industry has
its dope [__] I mean you have a ton of
geese yeah but if they're all I've been
bought it how many how many geese does
one master need exactly two how many do
you have no [__] way bro dirty to
wash them I have like I probably have
like eight G's oh my
twice a day sometimes
you just swap them out Ryu only has one
this is over this is cut off shoulders
and it stays white the whole time no you
got like 30 of them dude you got shoyo
rule you got the what's up doing the AP
brand one yeah but sometimes I get them
for free though you know what I mean
sometimes dude no okay
um probably my boxing mitts my boxing
miss those were like oh winnings yeah
those are expensive I got I got I got a
bunch of winning stuff but the thing is
that's like the so it's like if you're
not even they're so [__] sick winning
pads and gloves most stores don't even
carry them and until I think super rare
started stopping them you had to buy
them from a website that has to order
from Japan and it'll take three months
oh my God so I bought see people did I
give you my winning ones yeah I have the
headgear I still have it people aren't
the Gucci shoe they don't even know but
I have uh it's a winning gloves it was
like it was like 500 bucks and it took a
year for this Japanese guy to make it
[__] Everlasting kill 25 dollars
this guy makes all the myths for like
Floyd Mayweather yeah
how many naps does he take you're
probably a lot what about what's your
most expensive fanny pack
probably the Dakine one and I was like
40 bucks maybe 30 bucks I bought a pair
of Lulu sweats for the first time okay
that's your most expensive oh that's and
it was like it was like 120 oh my God
principal I was like I was like I'm not
gonna do it and my wife was like you
need to buy you need because she was you
know she was dunking on my style
obviously not today but she was dunking
on my style saying like she's like I
asked her I was like what do you think
would you rank me on a scale from one to
ten for my style she said three oh is
she being honest or was she being flirty
I don't know dude either way flirty
either way it hurt my feelings no just
kidding no but but I was like we're
walking by Lululemon and she was like
let's go take a look and I was like all
right and I was like looking at all this
stuff and I was like I don't know if I
want to spend this kind of money on it
but then I put them on and I go okay
I'll buy it they're comfy they're worth
it is that like an El Salvador in three
or like an American three I think it's
an American three oh that's low yeah
that's really low and that hurt it got
me but that's probably I don't really
have anything it's like
Big Balls what about those sick ass
Ray-Bans you have on oh yeah Ray-Bans
these are a gift these are gifts people
don't even know people have your Miata
no I sold it oh [__] that would have
been my most prized possession bro yeah
classic car probably worth like 100 G's
if I still had it no it's not I just
looked it up
the biggest baller here is the eight
figure dude yeah
what's the most expensive thing that's
like 10 cars besides
all of my cars combined make like half
of the lowest Tesla
all of his cars come by the price is
like Bart's truck if like Power Rangers
made a Megazord that was like weaker
than the individual parts
uh a sedan but what are you doing
keyboard like you go for like the good
like what's the thing that you do that's
the good [__] I think the splurgiest
thing I do is just post made a ton of
food yes because I think that's the
dumbest thing you can do and I do it all
the [__] time but sometimes you're in
a time crunch you can't like if you
still have your DeLorean well yeah that
would probably but then even that was a
I bought the DeLorean for like 14k no
way yeah and I sold it for like 50. nice
so you got a free car dude you did a
good job because this thing's [__]
fun I had it I know and I had to [__]
have it for 12 years so and I put about
that much in it so break even
I wouldn't say that splurgy but yeah I
would say Postmates the worst thing
because it's lazy maybe we all spent a
lot on food I think it's have you ever
done your budgeting and you're just
because one time I spent like at least
three grand in one month I've eaten a
DeLorean a year in Postmates holy wow
dude food is food is a [__] bro
but I don't post mates at all what kind
of what's your average post-mate dollar
value it's I'm probably exaggerating
it's not that much it's like 20 bucks 30
bucks but I think I would post maybe
four times a week which I think adds up
to a lot yeah because I'm because you
know you're buying for two yeah um
that's about like a hundred bucks oh
right right you get a Swarovski Diamond
[__] a white tiger dude
I can't tell it to you I got a guy
coming back
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to be a competitive buyer
a sucker for dope [__] though yeah oh
like what you're a deer head you're
right yeah Gearhead anything like my
pants they're all clad because I was
like oh dude hey do you like those the
hex clad ones oh so I have all clad
which is the standard restaurant one
yeah yeah each pen is like [__] five
hundred dollars she goes and I [__]
suck at cooking but I just like it and
then I love it it is like the best pan
of my entire and I bought those too so I
don't I don't even need hex I had all
clad which is the restaurant like why do
you have a whole set I like dope [__]
dude [__] when I'm getting my house
built they're like oh what kind of
garage you're open or whatever right
mostly blush but whatever I'm like dude
show me their dope as [__] garage door
opener oh I got the single motor on the
side rotary I'm like I'm like which one
let me get a triple mode when another
[__] garage guy comes into my house
and goes oh damn you got the genie 5000
yeah I'm like tell me which one I get I
like random [__] like it's a hologram
or got blinds but then like none of them
worked or some [__] oh the ones in here
[Laughter]
how much
you don't even want to know dude how
much how much 40 000 40 000.
they wouldn't even work because so I
wanted a ball out because the Vegas
house had all these windows right yeah
so they're a big wins we go like this
it's supposed to go like this and the
feeling I was trying to get is like oh
yeah yeah and then it was like
another Galactic planetary
and like what the window some of the
windows are so [__] high you can't
even reach it yourself so you can't even
fix it I can't even fix it so like I'm
just [__] getting blinded in the eye
like at three o'clock every [__] day
so what does Geo say about that did she
go was that your idea or was that she's
like you're dumb as [__] yeah yeah I
think sometimes we both like cool [__]
yeah so we'll be in it's a team it's a
team and you both feel like what the
[__] what was the explanation for the
guy that put it in did you ever say hey
bud these [__] still hey buddy it's the
worst yeah I ended up I I hated his
service so much that um signed up for
you well we actually I think connected
he's he's a good salesman because he's
like kind of like a bro so he came in
like hey dude hey you work out I don't
know [__] you're like yeah a little man
yeah and then we started talking about
protein and [__] weightlifting so you
started thinking about the blind they
opened up his [__] his album and then
give me that one and I trust this guy
and he's like okay he's like do we her
own factories would get done like proud
for many weeks ended up taking like
three months I got suckered into it
that's the real blind right there
dude
you're an [__]
[Laughter]
one dude he is you just won it
wait so when you when you sold that
house was that like a major selling
point for the buyer
the went down in value because honestly
value
the buyer they really set on the washer
and dryer huh out of everything yeah
they came in and they're like can you
leave the washer and dryer what's that
so special sure
I think they're just trying to move in a
rush and they didn't want to deal with
back order or anything like they were
just coming from Texas he had a nice one
though and they were massive oh this is
because those ones they look like
spaceships they went to Best Buys
looking around
yeah hell yeah so there's like this LG
like there's like uh the LG ones and
then all that what's your sickest washer
and dry it goes well come with me
through the back technically we don't
even hold it on the floor
but this is what we have of course they
don't and then I was like
you know what to do he's like you never
go in the [__] dry cleaners again
I'll tell you that
is that like gear I like
tight dope just everything how much does
the best washer dryer cost at that those
won't even afford it dude yeah well
there there's like regular people good
[__] and then there's like crazy baller
you know what I mean you know like
regular stove is like Kenmore or
whatever right then you got people that
get [__] like biking or those crazy
Brands you never really hear of there's
Wi-Fi Hub in it yeah unless you're going
like a Mayweather's house yeah so at
Best Buy the top one was like this LG
one that was like maybe 1800 per
oh that's a lot less than I thought
describe your laundry experience is it
[__] absolutely incredible yeah about
laundry I don't know
I just like cool call her up dude what
the [__] yeah call her up
that's okay
hey what's the washer and dryer like in
your old house it's good
[Music]